[Music]
the european union funds projects and
initiatives
and sets common rules for the internal
market
appropriate data is needed to evaluate
the impact of these actions
data for evaluation should be relevant
to the desired objective or
outcome the intervention logic such as
how the action
is expected to impact the outcome and
the evaluation criteria
such as effectiveness or efficiency
let's look at an example in
eu policy the school fruit and vegetable
scheme which promotes healthy eating
habits
one possible outcome of the scheme could
be improved body mass index or bmi
this is a measurable indicator directly
related to the policy objective
it is fundamental to measure the bmi of
children from both schools taking part
in the scheme
and those not taking part as they offer
a comparison group
other important data to collect concerns
the amount of fruit and vegetables
provided to each child
data about other contextual factors that
may influence bmi
must also be considered such as other
policy interventions
or facts on eating habits and exercise
routines
reusing data from several administrative
sources
like school or population registries and
from
implementing the program dramatically
reduces
costs when collecting data for
evaluation if this is not
feasible part of the data could be
collected through surveys
planning is important and data from
different sources
should be linked so that the final data
set contains
all the relevant information the
competence center on microeconomic
evaluation
or ccme supports data-driven evaluations
to help the european commission
guarantee that eu action is effective
discover more about the competence
center and its resources
at our website
you